معجزة البرازيل الاقتصادية. في
عام الفين واحد عشر نفذ لولا
بوضع سقف لسعر الغاز نفاق معتبرا
ان سياسة السوق الحرة هي الحل
الاحداث والتطورات. كوريا
الشمالية تطالب امريكا وكوريا
برامج اصلاح اقتصادي ركزت على
الجانب الاجتماعي وتحسين حياة
سيوقف الحرب الاوكرانية موقف
يؤكده العالم من اقصاه الى
خمسين. فماذا عن الباقي يا سيادة
الرئيس? الحوار وليس غيره هو من
الغاز اذ قال وزير الطاقة سعد
الكعبي ان المقترحات الاوروبية
الفقراء بصورة هائلة. ليس هذا
فحسب. ولكن تحولت البرازيل خلال
عاليا من التنمية المستدامة في
جميع المجالات. لتوجه امريكا
من بسبب نسيانه عدد الولايات
فذكر اربعة وخمسين بدلا عن
ديونها بالكامل. وتحولت الى دولة
مقرضة بعد ان كانت وها هو يعود
تشتعل بين روسيا وبريطانيا هنا
عملاء روس يخترقون هاتف رئيسة
الامثل دائما. تلاسن ومشادات
المغرب والجزائر تخيم على اعمال
الى السلطة بعد ان غادرها قبل
اثني عشر عاما. وبعد محاكمته
المخابرات بصدد تقديم وثيقة سرية
الى الكونجرس بهذا الخصوص فعن اي
السلطة البرازيلية. ليصبح معشوقا
للفقراء هذا الرئيس الذي حقق
سرية يتحدثون لقد عشنا في وهم
الكائنات الفضائية وغزو
خرجوا الى الشارع واعينهم تذرف
الدمع? هو ليس عزاء بل بفوز لولا
لاثنين سجن ظلما لاكثر من عشرين
عاما بتهمة القتل. سخرية واسعة
السوبر بالسعودية. الجنيه المصري
يواصل انخفاضه لاربعة وعشرين
عكسية بين موسكو وواشنطن وبكين.
فكلما زاد التوتر ضد امريكا
نقف مكتوفي الليل امام هذه
الاستهدافات. فما الذي يخطط له
القمة العربية بسبب الخريطة.
خلافات الجيران تستبق لم الشمل
لينقذها من جديد. فماذا عن حال
العراق ولبنان والسودان واليمن?
ضربة للاقتصاد الصيني. حيث
اشتعلت حرب الرقائق وفرضت واشنطن
الروسية بطرح القضيتين امام مجلس
الامن ويضيف الكريملين نحن لن
بالفساد لكن المحكمة برأته.
داسيلفا من ماسح احذية الى رئاسة
الروس يا ترى. هجمات الصين
تتعدد. علاقات دولية تمضي بصفة
الطايرة كانت عيونا تجسسية
صينية. الصحيفة ايضا ان
اسعار الطاقة موضحا انه اذا لم
تفعل ذلك فانه سيطلب من الكونجرس
الجنوبية بوقف التدريبات
العسكرية المشتركة فورا. قطر
الضوابط تلزم كل الشركات
الامريكية بالتوقف عن تزويد
ارتفع رصيد الجمائل والصداقات
ليعلن رئيس الصين في الذكرى
داسيلفا في الانتخابات
البرازيلية. عاد لولا داسيلفا
العربي في الجزائر فيما تستعد
العاصمة الجزائرية لاستقبال
الصين بتلك الرقائق. لكن اصحاب
العيون الضيقة يسبقون الامريكان
القادة والرؤساء العرب لعقد
قمتهم والثلاثين فاللهم لم شملهم
موسكو لندن بالهجوم على خطي نولد
ستريم وبالضلوع في هجوم بمسيرات
امام الدولار. بي بي سي. ستة
وثلاثون مليون دولار تسوية
قاسية. في هذه الحرب وقع صيد
اوكراني ثمين في قبضة نعم. وبعد
ضوابط جديدة للحد من قدرة بكين
على تطوير رقائق الحوسبة هذه
الوزراء المستقيلة ليزيتراس
عندما كانت وزيرة للخارجية
تنقلب على القارة العجوز لتصفها
بالمنافقة بعد تحرك اوروبي تجاه
على حمل النووية الى قاعدة جوية
في شمال استراليا. وهو ما قد
واطفي نار الفتنة بينهم. اسرائيل
تعلن مشاركة احد رياضيها في دور
والروس. ما بين الامس واليوم
سيكتبه الغدو كذكريات. لكن ما
الروس الذين يتم قتلهم في
المعارك وبكل بساطة يفتح هواتفهم
استهدف الاسطول الروسي في
سيباستبول وتعهدت الخارجية
الفضائيين للارض. معشوق الفقراء.
لماذا يبكي هؤلاء يا الهي لقد
بين موسكو ولندن يكتب التاريخ
حربا من نوع اخر. معركة التجسس
الجيش الروسي. فكيف سيكون
الانتقام? وهنا الرئيس الامريكي
بلاده ستأخذ هذه الخطوة
بالاعتبار بتخطيطها العسكري.
جو بايدن يأمر النفط الكبرى
باعادة استثمار ارباحها في خفض
ارسال ما يصل الى ست قاذفات
قنابل من طراز بي فيفتي تو قادرة
بخطوات. وبعد غموض دائم لسنوات
صحيفة النيويورك تايمز. الصحون
اقوى اقتصاد في العالم. وخلال
خمس سنوات فقط سددت البرازيل
السكنية بشكل كامل. لتطلق
السلطات الاوكرانية صافرات
ليتصل ويسخر من اهاليهم ليلعب
القدر اليوم لعبتهم ويقع في قبضة
الخامسة والستين لتأسيس جمعية
الصداقة الروسية الصينية ان
الاسلحة النووية والقنابل ذات
السقوط الحر في اوروبا مؤكدا ان
طول انتظار انه القائد الاوكراني
والذي كان يتصل بامهات الجنود
ليرد الكرملين انه لا يمكن
لموسكو ان تتجاهل خطط تحديث
تصاعد التهديدات النووية بين
القوتين العظميين روسيا امريكا
العلاقات بين البلدين دخلت حقبة
جديدة لافتا الى انها تظهر مستوى
السيناتور ما يقول ومن معركة
الغذاء الى حرب القنابل حيث اكدت
ويسربون معلومات ومحادثات سرية
للروس بحسب ديلي ماي. بينما تتهم
الانذار من جديد. وتدعو السكان
للاتجاه للملاجئ يا لها من حرب
التقارير ان امريكا لديها ما
يقارب مائة قنبلة نووية موجودة
فرض ضرائب على ارباحها الزائدة
بحسب فرانس بريس. حرب الانجليز
تلك الفترة من بلد ينهش الفقر
اغلب سكانه الى بلد يتمتع بسادس
يثير غضب الصين حليفة روسيا. فهل
يرد الحلفاء ومن معركة القنابل
الروسية. الجيش الاوكراني اطلق
اثني عشر صاروخ هايمرز على جسر
سترد بكين? وبعد غموض لسنوات
الصحون الطائرة يتم الكشف عن
راسكن ويصرح ان روسيا دولة
مسيحية ارثوذكسية ذات قيم
تقليدية ولهذا السبب يجب تدميرها
باي ثمن كان. وهذا جهاد بهيع
في منطقة خرسون وتم اعتراض تسعة
منها بينما سقطت البقية بالقرب
يقول الرئيس الاوكراني يا سادة
خرج السيناتور الامريكي جيمير
المراقبون ان موسكو وعدت بانها
ستعطي كل الدول الفقيرة الذي
القنابل المرعبة يا اصدقاء. اذا
القنبلة النووية في طريقها الى
سيتوفر طعام على موائد الناس في
مصر والجزائر واليمن وبنجلاديش?
بثلاثمائة الف عسكري اضافي ويمنع
تصدير الحبوب. هذه الحبوب شغلت
المدن الاوكرانية لتنقطع
الكهرباء والماء عن الاحياء
يحذر امريكا وجارته الجنوبية
وقطر تقلب الطاولة على اوروبا
النووية نعود الى الحرب
الاوكرانية. هنا خدمة الطوارئ
تحتاجه مجانا. فهل ستفعل ذلك
حقا? ليأتي الرد منزل نسكي.
داخل قواعد حلف باوروبا بما
تمتلك روسيا ترسانة نووية ضخمة
من الجسر. لترد روسيا بتكثيف
الهجمات الصاروخية وعلى كافة
موزعة بمناطق عدة في البلاد من
شرقها الى غربها يا لاعداد
القارة الاوروبية في موعد مبكر
عن موعدها المقرر. والسبب هو
الروسية وانسحاب قواتها الى حدود
عام واحد وتسعين. بينما قال نائب
الاحوال وتبقى اوكرانيا في
مواجهة روسيا على انفراد. لتعلن
بينما كشفت هيئة الاذاعة
الاسترالية ان امريكا تعتزم
روسيا تتسبب في مجاعة واسعة
النطاق في اسيا وافريقيا كما
تقبل بالحوار لكن كييف تضع
شروطها وامريكا تنشر قنابل نووية
لماذا يمكن لحفنة من الناس في
الكرملين ان يقرروا ما اذا
الخارجية سيرجي لافروف هنا يؤكد
ان روسيا وعلى رأسها الرئيس
كييف وتضع شروطا للحوار مع موسكو
اهمها وقف العمليات العسكرية
وزيننسكي يصرخ ومعركة التجسس
تشتعل بين موسكو ولندن وبين
العالم يا سادة. فبعد ان منعت
روسيا تصدير الحبوب يقول
روسيا والصين علاقات متينة ولكن
المرة من نوع اخر بينما تواصل
وتصفها ولوحة في الحائط تتسبب في
سجال حاد بين المغرب والجزائر.
البنية التحتية ومحطات الكهرباء
في البلاد ولا يعلن التعبئة
فلاديمير بوتين لا يزال مستعدا
للتفاوض بشأن اوكرانيا. لترد
وزير الاوكراني نيكولينكو ان من
يريد التفاوض لا يقوم بتدمير
مصدرها وملمع الاحذية يعود ليحكم
البرازيل من جديد. وكيم جونج
الولايات المتحدة تضييق الخناق
على اصحاب العيون الضيقة فكيف
لغة الحوار الروسي. تتبدل
الاوضاع وتتغير الاوجاع وتضيق
اوراق الكثير ونزع التوتر.
والمصالح الروسية خط احمر. وزير
موسكو انها لا تعارض لغة الحوار
لكن لغة الحرب تجعلها مدركة قيمة
اقصاه. وما كانت تطلبه اوكرانيا
ها هي روسيا توافق
جديدة في اماكن جديدة وروسيا
ترد. اوكرانيا في ظلام دامس
بعد طول انتظار صيد اوكراني ثمين
يقع في قبضة الجيش الروسي وموسكو